hi there happy new year
steve here steve kaufman to talk about
language learning
and today i'm going to talk about the
importance of novelty of new things it's
a new year and why we need new things
when we learn languages or maybe other
things as well
2018
wow you know i remember when i was uh
i guess a teenager we had
the novel 1984 by george orwell
and
seemed like a long way into the future
and here we are 2018.
new novelty um i often refer
to a book
by
manfred spitzer
okay
called learning
unfortunately
brain research and the school of
learning of life school of life
he said in there something that i think
is quite profound and it affects
language learning and that is that the
brain needs and he's a brain surgeon
he's a neurosurgeon cognitive sort of
science and stuff the brain needs
repetition
but it needs novelty
okay we need new things we can't just
keep repeating
studying the same material
um
you know robert bjork of ucla has a
bunch of videos where he talks about
interleaving where
you know if you block learn if you try
to learn this one
thing
eventually
this sort of law of diminishing returns
sets in you're learning less and less we
need novelty so
the one thing i because i've been
studying i have these 10 mini stories uh
in link which i've been studying and
listening to i've listened to them 30 40
times re-read them and and still the
same places i don't understand i don't i
read it wrong again and so forth
but
today
uh we uploaded another 20 stories many
stories into link
because i don't control that this is
done by
our collaborator zoran in serbia who has
found someone on upwork which is a
outsourcing website to translate these
stories and record them in arabic and
she by the way is doing a wonderful job
and so another 20 were loaded up i just
got started so even though i haven't
mastered the first 10 stories
the idea i'm like a kid in a candy store
now i've got these news stories that i
can go in and pick my way through and
listen and
and you know as i work my way through
these and again i'll not understand and
whatever but all the while i'm exposing
myself to the language and gradually
everything becomes clearer gradually the
writing system becomes clearer more
words start to stick
and i often remind myself you know what
you know i'm as as much as i'm
determined to sort of learn these 10
stories and
try to get better at them and even not
master them but at least understand more
of them
and i am understanding more but i'm not
moving as fast as i would like then i
remind myself you have to interject
you have to inject rather some novelty
so
at that even a couple of days ago i said
okay
i have
got a sense of the arabic alphabet let's
see how it all works in farsi and some
years ago i bought this
um living language uh farsi course so i
started listening to a bit of pharisee
of course i don't understand a thing and
started reading the first few lessons
here
uh it's
just to see for example the arabic
alphabet with a different language it
interjects injects rather some novelty
and i know i'm going to continue on to
farsi later on
but now that i have the new stories
uh at link i will you know i may just
put my i might still every so often have
a peek at farsi but i will stay with the
news stories but the important thing
there is is to in inject novelty get
some things in there that are new
that stir up the brain the brain likes
to be stimulated and to some extent if
we keep on
sort of plowing the same
furrows in the field
after a while we're not we're not
achieving anything so very important by
the way not everything new is good
i had a look at the the newer version of
this living language
and it is much worse than this one which
was published in 2007
for whatever reason living language has
completely dumbed down their language
courses lots of pictures and stuff like
this and so i certainly will not be uh
be using that material we do have
again zoram has
is searching for farsi speakers to help
us with the many stories in farsi
apparently 1 to 15 have been done
very good audio quality so
i will get out of that
but i do enjoy using books and certainly
this older version
of the living language series makes an
awful lot more sense than what living
language is doing now
and this was my experience with the
hebrew and the greek i found them i
bought them both on amazon but i found
them quite useless
so there you have it happy new year make
sure that in the new year
you don't just keep
you know pushing and pushing and pushing
on a limited amount of material and
repeating it you have to do some of that
but you also have to make sure you
provide your brain with novelty with
stimulus with interest and if you keep
varying it you'll probably make some
progress as i hope to make progress in
my arabic
thank you
and all the best for the new year
oh
oh oh oh i forgot to mention
that um
our survey of whether people are
holistic learners
or um you know detailed or or bits and
pieces learners grammar learners
uh i think it was basically
uh three to one in favor of holistic
learners so most people are holistic
learners
learn from gradual exposure to the
language not necessarily deliberately
trying to nail down words or grammar
rules but gradually allowing the brain
to get accustomed to the language
but do vary it enough spice it up with
some novelty in there
and you know while i'm
it reminds me of something else
um
when um
you know this sort of computer
translation
was first developed it was thought that
somehow the application of the sort of
grammar logic of languages would be key
to enabling computers to translate
things and it turns out that that was
not the case it turns out that it was
the sort of massive
uh exposure exposing the computer to
massive amounts of as it turns out
material from
the canadian parliament where everything
is is translated from english to french
or from french to english and so that
gave them sort of massive massive
amounts of of content whereby the
computer could identify patterns
and the way we learned i think is very
much that way
obviously some theoretical
grammatical explanation can help it's
not harm but more than that just as with
the computer
we have to let the brain identify
patterns
by massive exposure
but that exposure
you do need to move on to new stuff you
can't just stay with the same old stuff
all the time
okay
bit of a ramble there bye for now
[Music]
you